[Music]
ariana grande continues to mourn the
loss of her ex Mac Miller after he died
from an apparent drug overdose in
September on Monday the singer shared
that sweet throwback video of the rapper
suited up for a 2018 Oscars party one of
the last public appearances they made
together as a couple
Oh Thurman just be there for each other
isn't that just Ken cuz you know it's
clear Ariana has had a rough year
Miller's sudden passing calling off her
engagement with Pete Davidson and
announcing she's taking some time away
from social media I think that me being
open with my fans and my supporters it's
like a very important thing because like
it's like life but Ariana hasn't totally
stuck to staying off social media
she continues to post clips of her and
Pete's pet pig piggy smalls which she
featured in the music video for her
latest single breathing
[Music]
just weeks after the Popstars breakup
with Pete she also posted a cryptic snap
to her insta story that read protect
your piece get rid of toxicity cleanse
your space cultivate love a source told
et the SNL star is heartbroken over
their split adding ariana made the final
decision pete is still so in love with
her he wanted his whole world to revolve
around her but she was emotionally
unavailable
[Music]
despite Ariana and Pete split another
source told ET they still love each
other adding quote they are remaining
positive and looking forward to a future
together where they may be best friends
and still haven't ruled out the
possibility of one day making their
relationship work
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]